what is a lease option agreement or a
lease option agreement is when you buy a
property now
but you pay for it later
and you can do this on land you can do
this on residential houses you can do
some commercial houses
geez we have people calling the lease
option boot camp they stopped doing
lease option agreements on businesses
or businesses maybe you can even do a
lease option agreement
partnerships all kinds of stuff when you
grasp this
which is a worldwide way of doing things
now the really interesting thing is
poor people get encouraged
to do buy now pay later on
liabilities so poor people get
encouraged by the adverts
and by the media to buy
a sofa now and pay for the sofa later
now is that a stupid thing to do not
really because
you know you say you're keeping some
money back and we know that money
shrinks over time
so if you've got to pay for it later
then good so it's not bad
but it's okay but is the sofa going to
go up in value or down in value once you
sit on it
it's going down going down unless i'm
sitting on it right then maybe it goes
up
no just it's definitely going down it'll
break
okay so the sofa goes down what about
what other things do the media
and the adverts encourage you to buy now
and pay for later
car cars cars
perfect example where what what what
will you do what's like a typical kind
of what do they call it a ppp something
pcb
what does that stand for personal
contract
hire and how does a pcp work
personal purchase whatever it is but how
does it work
you put down a small deposit yeah then
you pay a small monthly fee
and then at the end of the term usually
after about five years
they had give you an option
and they give you an option to do what
to pay a balloon payment because they
call it
are you if you've got if you guys bought
cars this way you have sam
yeah it's sound right yeah yeah you
bought a car this way did you buy at the
end
of the day no i've just changed it you
traded
it so at the end you have the option to
buy the car and look away or
to give it back get a new one
or to just walk away
and guess what when the car sales would
explain this i i start salivating
i'm like you guys have good explainers
and i'm thinking they could be so rich
if they just did this in property
because they get it
okay buy now pay later
what is that what a car does a car
go up or down in value down
but does everybody say that's smart that
makes sense
does everybody accept that that's a
smart thing to do
yeah yeah but then when you talk about
doing it with a house people oh be
careful
what why do people say be careful
because they haven't conceived it
and they don't believe it and they don't
believe it for them
and that's okay but you can believe it
and conceive it for you and then you'll
receive it for you and then i'll say
so what else holidays
buy this holiday now go to
um croatia
barbados and pay for it next summer
what why why why do these advertisers
check why do these advertisers say this
why do they want you to bite now by
friday
because you don't have to put down too
much money you make it very accessible
accessible it's because people can't
afford it
they want it but they can't afford it so
the advertisers go right
or the marketers well they want this
over
they can't afford it so how can we put
together a
strategy of making it possible and guess
what i've done
the same for houses why because when i
was 17 i really wanted to buy properties
but i couldn't afford it
so i'm like how can i put together a
strategy
where i can buy a house but pay for it
later
now i just wanted a house because i just
wanted a house i wanted a house because
i was just like
i just want the feeling to be able to go
i've got the keys
that's the truth when i was 19 years old
i spent 18 months trying to get a house
i bought my first thousand on 17 and my
first house i bought when i was 17 years
old was actually
kind of a lease option agreement in a
way but it was really badly done
would you like to hear the story yeah
yeah okay the most the worst
options but
when i was 17 in 2008
i wanted to buy a house and the strategy
at the time
was a little bit like the brr strategy
that we would the people were doing and
i've had a lot of money going on courses
i went on different courses with
different training providers most of
them have gone bust now because of the
recession that came
because what they were teaching was they
were teaching um buy a house
for say um finding for 120
negotiate to buy for 100 below market
value
and buy on a bridging loan and with
angel investors money or whatever raise
the money
raise the money buy 400 and then the
same day you buy it
cash refinance it
back up to its true value on an 80
mortgage and then pay back the angel
investors in the bridging or whatever
and then you end up with a free house
that was without teaching can be honest
pretty much the same as what we do now
but the only difference is instead of
buying it cheap
and then refinancing it we buy it cheap
and then we
force the value up by adding things like
bathroom
um whatever and you'll learn all that
have you guys been on the boardwalk you
finance
masterclass not yet
you've been on it how was it i mean
okay good so so that's the whole
strategy of what what to do
now the problem was i was 17 i could
find the houses
i could even find the money but the
problem was i was 17.
so i had no credit i was too young to
buy a house
i just had nothing i'd know a way of
buying a house
even though i had the knowledge so what
i did
was i did it and at the time i didn't
know it was a lease option agreement but
it kind of was
but with my stepdad so what i did is i
said to my stepdad
tim who i love to this day i said to him
look tim you've got a decent job and
and credit and stuff like that i found
this
house i found the money
i found the house i'll be able to
refinance it the same day
i buy it but i haven't got the credit or
anything like that so
can you buy it
in your name and i
samuel leeds will have an option
to buy the property off of you when i
can get the credit and i'll and i'll buy
it off you and
and we'll do it tim so that tim will
step up so that you don't profit or lose
from the deal
you're literally just hosting the
property for me
that was that was how we agreed the
first deal so tim bought it for 100
grand
and we financed it for 120 it was a free
house it was in his name
but i had an option to buy it down the
line